hi there steve kaufman uh today i want
to talk about
um
again following up on the recent
videos that i've made about uh thinking
in the language and how it's very
difficult to judge when we in fact think
in the language or to figure out when we
increase our ability to think in the
language rather than to translate and
i've done videos about
the fact we don't learn a language as
much as we get used to a language and
someone brought to my attention
a video by a man called tim ferriss
tim or tom
tim ferriss i think it is uh who talks
about deconstructing a language and his
secret to learning a language quickly
and so i want to talk a little bit about
that and refer it to sort of to my own
experience all right so tim ferriss has
a list of i think nine or 12 sentences
that he uses in order to deconstruct a
language you know i have an apple i give
you an apple this is my apple i eat the
apple
things of this nature
and you can easily find it in fact i'll
give a i'll put a link in the
description box
to one of the videos because i kind of
looked him up people brought him to my
attention and i had been aware of him
perhaps as much as 10 years ago and and
had
i think i even did a video on him and
then i forgotten about it
um
but so these 12 sentences
to him represent basically
what you need to know about a language
in other words you deconstruct the
language i think he actually had a video
at one point that said learn any
language in an hour or learn about a
language or
implying that this is somehow a shortcut
to learning the language
well
my view is that
these 12 sentences or however many they
are
you know
it's a good idea and i think now with
with modern technology i would take
these 12 sentences or another 20
sentences and put them into google
translate get them translated into the
language you're learning
if you're on link import them into link
learn the words
and a lot of the basic word order and
how negatives are structured how
questions are structured how pronouns
are used whether adjectives come before
or after the verb all this stuff you
will see some examples of it
which is not bad
however
i think we need to be realistic as to
how much this helps you
my biggest struggle when learning a
language is acquiring words thousands
and thousands of words so 12 sentences
where a lot of the same words repeat is
not helping helping me acquire lots of
vocabulary however it is useful and in
the many stories that we have at link a
lot of the basic structures of the
language do in fact appear
and and uh repeatedly so that we can
start getting used to them
just knowing what they are is is not the
same as getting used to the structures
of a new language and learning a
language is largely a matter of
acquiring new habits getting used to a
new way of saying things including
learning the words and phrases
phrases which very often embody the
grammar of the language and sometimes if
we're interested we'll look up the
underlying grammar rules which we at
least in my case i quickly forget
but by being exposed to enough of the
language over enough time
i get used to it and the most common
sort of structures and the basic word
order and how questions are asked and
how negatives are structured we
encounter that very early so in that
sense it may not really be necessary
to
take these 12 sentences and learn them
or study them or memorize them however
there's no harm in doing that and and
what he suggests is that this gives you
on one sheet of paper or one
screen
sort of a certain range of structures
but it's not the full range of
structures because in any language you
know
if we're talking you know in 12
sentences where you're trying to cover
pronouns and verbs and present and
future there's lots of different past
tenses in some languages
there can be some continuous there can
be subjunctive
there can be literary language there can
be so many different things that you
don't cover it
and the second thing is as part of this
whole getting used to the language
i always find that
when first confronted with a structure
in a new language i don't necessarily
believe that that's how they say it it's
like my friend who was studying chinese
with me when we discovered that the
chinese in order to say are you going
they say nichibuchu you go not go and
and said like really they say that but
like in russian when you know one year
is
two three or four years is
and five and more is lit and when you
first come across it's like are you
serious that's what they do
and yet after a while all of these
little aspects of the language start to
become with enough exposure
you know we start to get used to it so
what i wanted to say on this is that it
can be helpful
to take tim versus 12 sentences
translate them but of course if it's in
another writing system like even in in
the latin alphabet if i were to do this
say in finnish which i don't know at all
just to see 12 finnish sentences but i
don't know what any of the words mean is
doesn't necessarily do a lot for me
not to mention if we're talking about
say arabic
where i can't even read it if i'm new to
the language so
it's there it can help us but to me it's
not a significant secret to speeding up
the process of language learning and i
should point out by the way that tim
ferriss you know i've heard him speak a
number of languages and he speaks them
very well and everyone has their own
favorite
thing that they do
that they believe helps them learn
languages better and they enjoy doing
them and therefore they're effective for
them
but i just feel that as a general
statement
learning a language is such a gradual
process of of getting acclimatized to a
new linguistic environment that just
knowing 12 sentences certain basic
structures word order negatives question
marks
it doesn't take you
a long way into the language because
actually to be good at a language you
need a lot of words and as i constantly
say that requires a lot of listening and
reading and eventually using the
language
and maybe when you go to use it to
refresh your memory you can go to this
these 12 um sample sentences that it
might help you but again when speaking i
don't think you'd want to be referring
back to a particular you know list of
sample sentences you want to be relying
on the fact that you've had so much
listening and reading that certain
patterns and structures in the language
just come out naturally in the form of
words and phrases that you have
basically absorbed so there you have it
my take on
tim ferriss deconstructing a language in
order to learn it thank you for
listening bye for now
[Music]
you